the visually stunning and heartfelt soul
is one of pixar's most acclaimed films
to date
and hidden in the movie are stacks of
deep cut references to other classics
such as inside out toy story and wally
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing every easter egg and
crucial detail you might have missed in
pixar's soul
there are some spoilers so take care the
best place to begin our soul
easter egg hunt is in the hall of
everything one of the locations in the
great before where new souls go to find
their spark
in the sky you can see charles muns's
blimp the spirit of adventure from
pixar's up
floating in the distance and a little
more difficult to see is the axiom from
wally one of the giant star line of
spacecrafts built by by and large during
the evacuation of earth
and the monorail is a nod to metroville
and the second
incredibles movie where the city's
monorail track was destroyed during the
battle with the underminer
back on the ground the aztec temple is a
reference to coco's land of the dead and
the stone structures that form the base
of the buildings in that movie's
afterlife
and another coco easter egg crops up
later on when 22 is deliberately messing
with humans in the zone
after she interrupts the tattoo artist
you can spot a very coco style skull and
a portrait on the wall
the pizza planet truck with its
distinctive red and white rocket on the
roof is here in the hall
the truck originally appeared in pixar's
very first feature film toy story and
has shown up in almost every pixar film
so far
and resting on the side of the truck is
a double bass an instrument that's also
prominently on display in joe's
apartment
the garbage truck behind the pizza
planet truck is likely a toy story three
reference to the truck that sid worked
on as a garbage collector and the one
that lotso ended up on at the end of
that movie
you'll find the a113 easter egg on a set
of street signs in the hall of
everything
the appearance of a113 in pixar's films
is a tribute to the classroom at
california institute of the arts where
many of the studio's animators studied
the suspended whale is a nod to finding
dory and the giant mammal on display in
the indoor exhibit at the marine life
institute
and this orange colored dinghy complete
with onboard motor and two souls sitting
inside
tips its hat to another scene from that
movie where two workers from the
institute picked dory out of the ocean
after they discover she's caught in a
piece of plastic
and further back is the pixar lamp aka
luxo jr who made his first pixar
appearance in a short film of the same
name
the lamp also appears on the production
logo of every pixar film
next to the lamp is a black piano an
allusion to the piano joe plays at the
half note club in new york
speaking of the club there was an easter
egg to one of its stars in onward via a
record by the dorothea williams quartet
in ian and bali's house because seoul's
director pete doctor also directed
inside out there are many shout outs to
that beloved movie in the hall
the tower with a pennant on top just
behind the temple appears to be from the
princess dreamworld castle in insides
out imagination land which was
demolished after riley's memories of it
faded
and the truck is a likely reference to
the same truck that the mined workers
used to plow old faded memories into the
memory dump
this purply blue trampoline is similar
to one which appeared in riley's early
childhood memories
there's also the golden gate bridge
which riley saw for the first time when
she moved to san francisco
and while trolleys aren't unique to san
francisco riley did marvel at one when
it drove past her family's car as she
arrived in the city
the studio chair could also be a
reference to the one rainbow unicorn sat
in at dream productions in inside out
an interesting brave easter egg pops up
in the video play during the mentor
training presentation by one of the
jerry's we see a soul find its spark
after it successfully fires an arrow
into the center of one of three targets
alluding to the scene where merida
demonstrates her archery skills during
the presentation of suitors by firing
her arrow into three targets
this large curiously shaped object
resembles a top heavy rock
called willy's butte that doc hudson
challenged lightning mcqueen to erase
around in the first cars movie
and the cactus plants down on the ground
might also be a call back to how during
that race
lightning ended up skidding out of
control and falling into a cactus patch
the passenger plane is likely a nod to
everett the jumbo jet that mata narrowly
avoided crashing into in the car's
sequel
and london's iconic big ben could be a
reference to big bentley where mata was
briefly imprisoned
the eiffel tower from paris which also
appeared in cars 2 is here as well
although this could also be a reference
to ratatouille
and this biplane here may be one of the
light aircraft flown by charles munso's
dogs in up
and it might also be a hat tip to barney
stormin the piston cup sky writing plane
from the first cars movie
the chessboard that a couple of souls
are playing is likely a shout out to the
pixar short film jerry's game in which
an elderly man plays chess with himself
this giant ferris wheel is probably a
reference to the fair ground attraction
from toy story 4.
the canoe is likely a shout out to
pixar's 2020 short film
loop and this large dog looks like it
could be either doug
or beta from up after joe and 22 leave
the hall of everything they go inside
just a box where the iconic pixar ball
makes its appearance
the luxo ball is a regular pixar easter
egg and a homage to the short film luxo
junior
the pink flamingo in this room could
also be a nod to the flamingo character
sunny florida from pixar's short film
knick-knack
also in this room is 22's collection of
her previous mentor's name stickers
there are a huge number of deceased
real-life historical figures who in the
pixar universe once tried to help the
obstinate soul find its spark
copernicus the world doesn't revolve
around you
22 muhammad ali you are the greatest
pain in the butt stop talking my
unconscious mind hates you
some interesting names you'll find here
that weren't mentioned in the movie
include joan of arc
confucius albert einstein the iconic
soul singer aretha franklin
and comic book legend jack kirby there's
also joe ramft one of pixar's original
animators who worked on all the studios
movies as well as voicing various
characters before he tragically passed
away in 2005.
there have been many tributes to him in
pixar movies over the years including
naming one of the scarers and monsters
inc after him
there are some nice extra details in the
scene where we discover that marie
antoinette was one of 22's former
mentors
notice that 22 is holding up a piece of
cake a reference to the phrase let them
eat cake that's been famously
misattributed to the last queen of
france
also notice how marie antoinette is just
a floating head without a body
referring to the fact that she was
beheaded during the french revolution
nobody can help you nobody and the way
she emphasizes and repeats the words no
body in this moment is a clever bit of
word play
the scene also reminds me of the funny
moment in toy story where buzz bemoan's
being made to have tea with two beheaded
dolls
you're defending the whole galaxy and
suddenly
you find yourself sucking down
darjeeling with
marie antoinette and her little sister
something particularly hard to find this
time around was the cameo by john
ratzenberger who's always voiced at
least one character in every pixar film
he's not credited in the movie but
listen very carefully as joe walks
through the hall of you
there are several on-screen characters
who tell him sorry joe as they turn him
down
and then off screen in the background
you'll hear ratzenberger's distinctive
voice say
we're looking for something different
there's also a fun detail in the scene
where 22 tries to find her spark by
experimenting with chemicals
the chemical formula for the compound
behind her is theobromine
one of the principal stimulants in
chocolate and notice how the chemical
reaction gives off a little cloud of
brown powder
this might also be a little shout out to
russell and kevin from up who are both
chocolate fans especially as that movie
was directed by pete doctor the director
of seoul
another pixar movie that doctor directed
was monsters inc and there's a moment in
the youth seminar that links back to
that film
after souls are paired up with their
mentor jerry conches up a door and sends
them through it
instantly transporting them to another
location this portal-like quality of
doors in the great before is similar to
how they work at the monster's inc
factory where monsters can cross over
into the human world through doors
and this detail is crucial for how soul
fits into the pixar theory
more on that later although many of the
personality pavilions in the great
before
were designed to be abstract looking a
few of them were deliberately given
specific
shapes by pixar's animators so the aloof
pavilion is shaped like a nose pointed
up in the air and there's also a little
icon of a person with their nose pointed
up just above the entrance
there's a clue to spiritual sign twirler
moonwin's ability to project his
consciousness into the astral plane by
the words on his t-shirt
living the dream the cnd piece symbol
pin that he wears on his jacket
is also the design of the anchor for the
ship he navigates whenever he gets in
the zone
and a much older piece symbol a giant
dove with an olive branch forms the
figurehead of that ship
the name of the group that moonwing
commands mystics without borders is a
play on the name of real life
organization med san san francis aka
doctors without borders
much of seoul also takes place in new
york and there are many pixar easter
eggs hidden around the city
for instance on the subway there's an ad
for a company called brang with the
slogan what did you bring
this is an ingenious easter egg to
riley's father from inside
out as brang is the name of the tech
startup company he joined in san
francisco
there's an easter egg to luca pixar's
next film after seoul in the window a
travel agency that joe walks past
the poster is a painting of an italian
seaside town
with the words visit puerto rosso luca
is a coming-of-age story set on the
italian riviera
when joe discovers he's in a new york
hospital there's a subtle clue that 22
will end up in his body if you look at
the monitoring machine by joe's bedside
because the model is a smart view px22
and it's no coincidence that 22 was
chosen for the name of the soul that joe
mentors because there's been a total of
22 pixar feature films prior to the
release of seoul
there's a lovely moment in the movie
when joe via 22 who's in his body has a
heartfelt conversation with his mother
on the wall in the room where this
happens is a little picture with the
motto
sowing men's the soul it might be a
common saying but it also has a double
meaning in this moment because this
conversation with joe's mother is
crucial for 22 finally coming round to
understand the pleasures of living and
life on earth
and so this scene literally mends the
soul that we know as 22.
there's a funny moment when joe as mr
mittens goes to fetch a slice of pizza
for 22
and as he returns he sees a rat dragging
a piece of pizza along the floor
an amusing reference to the pizza rat
meme that went viral in 2015.
also here is an interesting bit of
graffiti which looks like it might be a
second
a113 easter egg i can't say for sure as
the potential a is more of a triangle
here but the a113 easter egg did appear
as a graffiti in inside out which as i
mentioned earlier was also directed by
pete docter
there's an interesting potential
connection between soul and toy story 4
that you can see by the name of the
removal company move it
whose trucks on the road where joe falls
down the manhole
it seems plausible that the move it
removals business could be connected to
the ship it delivery company which had a
truck parked outside the antique store
in the fourth toy story movie
shipit first appeared in the toy story
of terra short where a courier working
for the company was picking up packages
from the sleepwell motel
and there's a deep cut disney easter egg
in this scene by the name
rhett law on this van this is a
reference to rhett law
enterprises originally known as walt
disney miniature railroad
a company set up by walt disney himself
in 1950 to manage the rights to his name
and a couple of attractions at
disneyland that belonged to him rhett
lore is the name walter spelled
backwards
a regular easter egg in many of pixar's
movies is a chinese food box which makes
at least two appearances in seoul
you can see it on the hedge fund
manager's desk here the box has a very
specific design and among other films
has appeared in soul director pete
doctor's inside out and monsters inc
while its first appearance was in a
bug's life where it was called the
chinese cabinet
of mythomorphoses you can spot
the same takeout box design later on
when joe crashes into a garbage can and
his hand gets stuck in a discarded box
the existence of recurring objects like
this box and so many pixar films like
seoul
is evidence for the pixar theory that
all of the animation studios films exist
in a single connected universe
and have made a separate full video
explaining exactly how seoul proves the
theory correct
there's a card here plus there's a link
to watch it in the video description
by the way i enjoyed how mr mittens the
therapy cat brought lots of physical
comedy to the new york part of the movie
and the art of soul book reveals that
the name of the cat therapy service he
works for
is called feline better a play on
feeling better
the art of book also reveals the meaning
behind the symbols on 22's pass
22 is apparently a moody extroverted
cynic who's extremely punctual
i can thoroughly recommend checking out
the art of soul book to appreciate and
learn much more
about many of seoul's early concepts and
how they progress to their final version
in the film
i'll add a link to where you can get the
book in the video description
now if you didn't sit through the
credits for seoul you might have missed
out on a little post-credit scene in
which terry pops up for
a final time hi movie's over
go home this is a joke in the spirit of
the post-credits scene in ferris
bueller's day off and also deadpool
which itself rift on that john hughes
film
and it's clearly intended for the
traditional cinema experience so it
doesn't work quite so well watching at
home on disney plus so it is a fun
little reward for those who sit through
the credits
now what other easter eggs or cool
details did you spot in seoul and how do
you rate it among your favorite pixar
movies
if you enjoyed this then a thumbs up is
hugely appreciated
next tap left to see how soul proves the
pixar theory that boo from monsters inc
travelled back in time to become the
witch in brave or tap right for
something else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippie kai movie lovers